un couple dans la vie une passion
commune le mythique rallye des gazelles
ces deux habitants de
vélizy-villacoublay vont participer
ensemble à la première édition de ce
raid
ouverte aux hommes on a toujours eu
cette envie de partir et partager notre
envie de conduire un 4 4 sur des pistes
on aime les grands espaces on aime le
maroc
un baptême du feu pour pascal burg le
sportif est partie de l'organisation
depuis 15 ans mais n'a jamais pris le
départ de l'épreuve
al'inverse sa femme fabienne lalande est
une gazelle chevronné a déjà participé à
quatre éditions donc le rallye il
approche le connaît il sait ce que c'est
mais je dirais en théorie par rapport
aux participants et alors le voir de
l'extérieur c'est une chose et le voir
de l'intérieur c'est autre chose et
c'est vraiment quelque chose de fabuleux
c'est une très belle aventure et ça
valait le coup qu'on le partage tous les
deux dans le 4 4 les rôles sont déjà
répartis pascal burg laissera le volant
à sa faim pendant toute la durée de
l'épreuve pour se concentrer sur
l'orientation interdiction d'utiliser un
gps seuls des cartes en noir et blanc
datant des années 60 et la boussole sont
autorisés ce qui me plaît dans la
navigation c'est toute la partie c'est
tout à fait moi en fait
intellectuel donc la réflexion le choix
de la stratégie
donc j'en sais ce que je vais travailler
puisque en temps normal je suis plutôt
au volant d'un véhicule des 4 4 mais là
je vais me mettre à côté
je vais essayer de guide et fabienne du
mieux que je puisse donc c'est vraiment
cette partie là qui m'a attiré c'est
vraiment mon gros de challenge pour être
prêt à 100% le jour j les deux
aventuriers pratique le hors piste
régulièrement dans les forêts de la
région parisienne avec leurs véhicules
une première approche de la compétition
sans l'étude maintenant moi je travaille
mes cartes fabienne de temps en temps
dès qu'on peut on roule roule au volant
du véhicule pour ne rien perdre et
surtout apprivoiser on va dire le
véhicule ce duo encore quelques mois
pour dompter ce 4 4 le gaz et les
domaines est programmée du 4 au 11
novembre dans le désert marocain